يقف على اطلال البيت الذي كان ياويه قبل
ايام
محمود لا يدري ما الذي جرى له متى وكيف
واين هو الان في حضن جده يستمع لقصه ليست
من نزج الخيال بل هي قصه نجاته من هول
الزلزال والله يعني موقف مرعب لدرجه هو
ساكنين طابع الرابع انه هي عم تنهد
البنايه
والله خد امانته
والحمد لله يعني صابه خفيفه براسه والحمد
لله واهله الله يرحمهم راحوا
طابق الرابع حكايه نجاه محمود تناقلتها
الالسن وايثار والده حياه ابنه على حياته
حول مجرى الحديث عن الكارثه الى معان
ساميه فخلال ثوان الزلزال المعدوده صب
تفكير الاب على انقاذ ابنه فيما لم يتمكن
هو وزوجته من النجاه
شو بدي اقول لك يعني قالوا لي الطفل بس
انه بخير
انه هاي صبرتني شوي والله لقوه هون هابين
هالبنيات هدول مع انه كله مهبط ولقوه هون
اول بيقعد بيحكي
هيك وجيت في الارض اوقيت ما بيرضى بيحكي
شي
مصدوم يعني تم هذا الحكي بس من يومين لحتى
حكى
سنوات وعمره الاربعه لم تحجب عنه اهوال ما
عاشه قد لا يعي محمود الان معنى نجاته
وهذا المكان الذي لجات اليه عائلته جراء
الحرب السوريه لم يعد له معنى الان لكن
هذا الركام الذي انهى حياه والديه والالاف
قد يذكر العالم بالمهجرين المنسيين ممن
بقوا على قيد الحياه كحلي محمود عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه